[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
crazy
crazy
all right
here we go we got it we're live we're
running we're not live but it's live tv
whatever what does it matter you know
we're we're live we're i'm doing this
live because i'm alive is basically what
i mean
and um
another week happy easter everybody
uh you know that was easter and my idiot
ass [ __ ] asked kristen if it was
easter all over the world or just in
america so she told me it was all over
the world so i guess jesus is worldwide
um
go figure man uh jesus is basically
[ __ ] what's his name uh
pitbull
yeah
pip
jesus is worldwide jesus
coming back coming back for that ass
resurrected
i forgive your sins um jesus back with
just sunglasses bald and [ __ ]
um
wearing a suit people no one would know
would you know who would know mexicans
would know uh mexicans would know mostly
because um of how mostly because of
uh pit bull but even mostly because of
jesus because nobody loves [ __ ] jesus
more than mexicans but um
except for italians really well you know
a lot of people love jesus but whatever
and white people down south
it it really depends um so it's another
episode of congratulations and i got
that oops merch on look i don't think i
realized i didn't wear it for this
um i haven't worn it yet wow i put the
wrong shoulder up
i haven't worn it yet
um but this is the oops merch we got it
on it's the t-shirt i'm gonna be you can
get that on chrisley.com i'm gonna be
bringing these t-shirts to arizona i'm
gonna be in arizona april 30th get your
tickets at crystallia.com get your merch
chrisleya.com and get your tickets to
the second show
in arizona april 30th because the first
one sold out yes dude
uh johnny fills them seats so uh that's
what's up man so i'm gonna be in uh
phoenix you know i never know whether to
take [ __ ] hoodies on the road when i
go when i do the road and i sell merch
on the road everyone's like you got
hoodies but hoodies are big to pack and
i can't have a lot of them on the road i
can't have as many hoodies as t-shirts
so i bring t-shirts but then arizona's
hot as [ __ ] you know it gets real hot
you go to arizona and you [ __ ] lip
crack immediately because it's dry and
hot as [ __ ] doesn't matter what
uh what month of the year it is honestly
well i was in arizona once and it was
january and it was cold as [ __ ] but
guess what still dry so no matter what
your lips be cracking in um in arizona
but i'll be in arizona on april 30th so
get your ticket to
crystalia.com um
still tickets left on that second show
uh but yeah i got the oops merch on and
it was easter wasn't it
so jesus was resurrected and he [ __ ]
died for our sins and then came back or
something and he's also his dad or
whatever it is i don't know god is like
the son of his son or i you know i don't
know i'm not really
religious i kind of checked out when
[ __ ] when i was at church
when the
the just the singing is really boring
you know
i lose it whenever you sing it should be
better right
like you're talking and talking and like
the priest was like and then the you
know
then jesus came down to the
[ __ ] well and he helped his
brother paul or something that wasn't
really his brother but everybody's
brothers right because we were brothers
in the human race but paul was down in
the well and then he gave
and then he he helped him with a little
plant that he needed a fruit he gave him
one single peach and paul made the peach
last for nine years like [ __ ] like that
in a
in a [ __ ] in the bible the bible's
always given they're always people are
always giving somebody one vegetable in
its last and he gave him
one one of his crops
and he and and and and
john let the that crop lasted him and
his family for 19 years
gave him an asparagus bushel and it
lasted john and his family for 19 years
and that's that's that's what the priest
is saying you know and like all right
it's kind of okay and it's
boring and [ __ ] and you're obviously
making all this [ __ ] up or someone did
because also who wrote the bible you
know what i'm talking about
nobody knows
it's like at least put john grisham on
the cover of it john grisham dude
the writer of the [ __ ] and in his new on
the new grisham novel it would be the
from the from the writer of rainmaker
and the bible and it would still say
rainmaker first that would be [ __ ]
awesome dude from the writer of of
andromeda strain and the bible comes
the firm too t-o-o and um
and uh and then they sing dude but when
they sing it's the only [ __ ] speaker
that when he starts singing it's more
boring dude
you know when david gray is out there
he's just like yeah this next song
reminds me of it you're just like get on
with it you know he's like i went
through a breakup a long time ago and
you're like yeah okay get out you're in
the [ __ ] third row just get on with
it though
and this is it
leave me a hand
alone and that's when you're activated
right
but in a [ __ ] uh
church in the catholic church he's the
only guy who gets more boring when he
sings
and then jesus goes down to the well and
gives him a bushel of asparagus
and you're just like wake me is he
trying to put me to sleep dude
dude any song that's a him is boring as
[ __ ]
dude if you want to make a [ __ ] song
way more boring him knit up
also the it's annoying there's an n in
there too
like songs are supposed to make the [ __ ]
better
[Music]
and ever and ever
so boring to add the end ever end ever
just
he did it all the time he did it forever
and that's it did he also do it end ever
yeah cause it's in the first forever
dude
don't make me be redundant
[Music]
and jesus came down to the to the desert
and gave mary a sheep and she made that
sheep last for
12 years just her and her family eating
that sheep
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude everyone's just in the [ __ ]
church in the pews just
anyway so let me please open up your
books what's that oh he's talking again
oh good that got boring as [ __ ] what was
it
what page open up your page is [ __ ]
way too long open up your open up your
book to page 398012.
what how [ __ ]
putting it on the thing
okay
opening it up like this
and the [ __ ] tassel out of it so you
get the bookmark and then the trachem
[ __ ] smacks you in the head give us
give us some dollars please man this is
boring as [ __ ] dude
it's the whole point
i just you know
at least with the [ __ ] muslims they
they get on the ground and you
understand like they're kneeling and
[ __ ] they gotta pray five times a day
and it's like oh okay then at least it's
like kind of in a way like
you know you're you're you're saying
yeah this isn't supposed to be fun
but like catholic church either make it
less fun or more fun dude it's like just
boring it's worse
make it worse or better
you know
it's like
you either like me or you don't you know
what i'm talking about like people
either they're on board with my [ __ ]
you're a part of this cult or they're
just like [ __ ] that guy he's too
aggressive he yells a lot i don't like
him at all he makes no sense he's too
silly
then you're just not on board
but like make it more i guess what i'm
saying is be more memorable right
the catholic church just they need some
[ __ ] pr or some [ __ ] get me in there
with my oops merch out there [ __ ]
oops imagine me out [ __ ] the oops
you're too boring yay in the back pew
yay
get some cushions on these [ __ ]
yay i'm the only guy taking money from
the [ __ ] plate they did that big ass
basket and i'm taking money is this how
much can we take
no it's for
it's for it's for uh donations
ah aren't you guys the richest
organization because it's [ __ ]
religion
don't you have money forever and ever
dude imagine if i was a priest and i was
up there doing it like that
wow man
i was never an altar boy and i went and
i did the catholic church and they would
[ __ ] and they would and they were
like do you want to be an altar boy and
i was like are you kidding me dude even
like as a kid i was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
yeah but what about getting closer to
god all right dude look if you're if
you're in your teens and you're getting
closer to god because you want to go on
a [ __ ] ski trip and it's a religious
ski trip or whatever i did that we went
to a [ __ ] ski trip for like young
life and it was uh
young life was uh this uh
it's probably still around but it's this
religious organization and they would
like try to trick you in to become a
religion by
[ __ ] um by taking you to like on a on
a a ski trip once a year and they'd be
like would you like to come to the
[ __ ]
would you like to come to the ski trip
and you'd be like sure and they'd be
like okay but you know a lot of god
songs on the bus on the way there and
you're like oh well okay i like
snowboarding so [ __ ] it
and then on the all the way up it would
be like jesus cares about you he'd give
you his last sandwich jesus cares about
you and then they would mix it in with
like [ __ ]
uh
bye miss american but nothing is more
white than that [ __ ] song i can't
stand that song dude put the chevron to
the lemon and the rabbits wouldn't dry
and the good old balls singing biscuit
in my this song i mean that song is for
so for [ __ ]
42 year old pasty white like chunky
white dudes that have like [ __ ]
that that just go like this a lot dude
classic
good oh boy just barbecuing with [ __ ]
pants and flip-flops on you know
and so uh they tricked me into going to
young life and then i didn't do young
life anymore because i'm like i can't
[ __ ] sing how many times can we sing
around in a circle dude
so i did the [ __ ] um
i did that one ski trip and then i'd
like took a few spills and i was like
first of all religion
like it's it's too much for me and then
also skiing coupling it with an a sport
that's just gonna like i gotta get too
much gear for it you know what i mean
like it just i gotta like th the fun
part of skiing is like
two percent of it
you're on the lift for forever and ever
ah
why would i want to do a sport where the
[ __ ] down time is eighty percent of
it you're on a ski lift and they don't
even go fast and then you get to the
skiing part and that's only two percent
of it because you zip down the mountain
and you're liable to hurt yourself
and everyone's wearing bright clothes
and it tricks you into liking it
no i'm not into it dude
and really the only good part is getting
hot cocoa
and that's the only [ __ ] part really
chicks like about skiing is being
bundled up in the cabin so what that
really means is they don't actually like
skiing they just like being inside it's
like when chicks say they love the rain
but then what they actually do is just
huddle up by the fire when it's raining
out because that means that you actually
don't like the rain if you're inside
[ __ ] you don't even realize it you
don't realize what you're saying
[Music]
well the most annoying podcast of all
time
dude oh if you like the rain then go
outside but you didn't stand in it
[Laughter]
be it make it make it like that movie
school ties
um
yeah dude so i'm i'm [ __ ] you know
that's why i'm not religious because i
don't like skiing
um
but yeah we did the [ __ ] dude we
would do we would do prank calls i would
call people and pretend i was the lead
the young lifeless the young live leader
talked like this i'm not you know i'm
not going to tell you his name so you
don't look them up on instagram but um i
would go uh i would call people i would
call people i would call friends and
people who were eating young life uh
young life because he would always say
every time
every time you'd see him like on campus
dude who are these [ __ ] guys they
would just be like on the high school
campuses these [ __ ] young life dudes
they would just be like 32 and they'd
just be like hey dude and the dude would
always be like hey how's it going wow i
just enjoy your energy you're just great
huh just always talking about like ah
you just put a smile on everybody's face
don't you and he would always say you're
coming to young life tomorrow night
you're getting a young life tomorrow
night you coming to young life tomorrow
night dude and i would just be like i
would call people up and i'd be like hey
michael how's it going just wondering if
you're giving a young life tomorrow
night
and then i would do this one thing
dude i would call people i would call
people
what an [ __ ] i am i would call people
collect calls from him and i would do
that part too i would just and i would
do the whole thing i would be like
i'm gonna make up his name so i don't
say his real name but say his name was
uh michael sebastian right so i would
just be like i would start it and i
would say you know how it goes
you know how he would say you have a
collect call from and then so i would do
but first i would go with my mouth i
would go well wow wow dude i would go
you have a collect call from michael
sebastian
press one two and then everyone knew
michael sebastian so that you i'd hear
boop i'd hear one and then i would say
and then i'll wait a little bit and i'd
be like and i would go like this
is it going hey like cut it in like with
my own voice i'd be like
get going hey thanks for accepting your
charges listen i was just wondering if
you're coming to young live tomorrow
night and then they would be like why
the [ __ ] did you call me
dude
and then i didn't realize how shitty it
was because then [ __ ] michael
sebastian would come up to me and he'd
be like hey you know you gotta stop
calling people and ask me if they're
coming to young life tomorrow night
collect calls
bro but it was so funny to do it when
you were 16. wow how sh how [ __ ]
shitty is that to do now i realize wow
yeah are you coming to young live
tomorrow night um anyway dude um
wow so bad
uh
so anyway i did that let's look at this
bad church singing
compilation i've always wanted to
[ __ ] out well this next and final
song is going to be one that has made me
pretty famous over the last few years
wow first of all cincy wiggling his feet
that's what happened
wiggling
[Music]
wow dude oh this [ __ ] bro i remember
this one no no dude i remember this dude
this was from way back from e-bombs
world this was the [ __ ] this one dude
holy [ __ ]
this guy's so ill
oh my god patrick bateman
has to return some videos after this
[Music]
so [ __ ] [ __ ] dude look at that house
in the back wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh this was the guy who sings oh amazing
grace but he definitely has like down
syndrome or something so we won't make
fun of him um oh amazing grace dude when
i was the oh my god when i did a [ __ ]
play one time i go to pro or no a
musical i do musicals dude i love
musicals i would do a musical now too
except for it gets in the way of stand
up but i would do i would do matinees up
the [ __ ] ass right now dude if
somebody wanted to hire me for [ __ ]
damn yankees i would do damn yankees
wednesdays and sundays at [ __ ] 1 30
p.m dude and i would kill it i would
kill it a [ __ ] i would do forget
it for real i would i would
i would just be like [ __ ] i would do
little shop hours i put a sign up right
in the front window advertisement right
in front window and all of a sudden
success coming out of the blue mushrik
and sun dude i would kill it
i love musicals but i did a musical
called me and my girl when i was in high
school and so and and the guy who played
one of the [ __ ] like the not the
butler i can't remember he always he was
the family solicitor was the guy i can't
remember what his name was but that was
his job i don't even know what a family
solicitor is but dude he had to sing
this song i'm the family solicitor and
you know it would go i'm the family
solicitor dude and he would always sing
i'm the fan mo leaf solicitor dude and
and we were all like dude he's saying
family
i'm the family solicitor and dude one
time the art teach or the the drama
teacher just said it's fair ma it's
family you're saying family and dude he
was never the same since
well i'll never forget that
the renewed mine is the key
the renewed mine is the key
are there other good ones in here i
should probably do more huh
i should probably do more here
a ghost
falling
falling
[Music]
all right it's just a couple i mean
that's a guy's a balloon so that's cool
that guy's a balloon good job guys
so anyway it was easter i hope you had a
good easter if you live in this world
because it's worldwide i don't know if
you know that but um yeah
it was easter beautiful
and i sat outside a little bit
i sat outside i was in the pool with my
son
and i sat outside a little bit and it
was [ __ ] amazing
and uh
somebody actually [ __ ] asked me they
said did you get some color now granted
it went away since then but i think i
still have a little bit of color maybe
even a little bit but it went away since
then it was a little bit more tan and i
was like yes yes i did dude
yes i did
dude
calvin watches this video
that goes
um
it's like it's just dude kids videos are
just so it's like i know they're for
kids but also like i don't want my kid
to be to grow up and be like
like you you have to make sure to watch
the right video for
the right age group right because like
you want him to develop but you don't
want him to you don't want to like dumb
him down and [ __ ] like like coco melon
forget it dude you i think they're
trying to start a [ __ ] cult like a
zombie cult it's so so so creepy
coco melon and [ __ ] like the dads are so
dumb you know
and and they're very creepy um with big
eyes and [ __ ] but the but but there's
one that but but also you don't want
like
so you don't want to dumb the kid up
right like how long can you watch
cocomelon like it's fine if you're five
months old but my son's two already and
like he can kind of talk so i don't want
my son growing up to be thinking that
like
i don't want him watching coco melon
because he's dumb as [ __ ] but
so he watches this one
because he's learning about foods and
[ __ ] and it's just like
it's just it'll be like do you like
donuts and then it'll go yes i do
do you like and then i'll say something
like do you like juice yes i do and then
it'll go
and then it'll say do you like
do you like donut juice and then he'll
go
no i don't
yucky
and and it's and dude it's so dumb and
i'm watching it and if i just like take
my son out of it i'm like i can't
believe i'm watching this [ __ ] but then
when calvin will like be walking around
the house he'll see something like that
like that he doesn't want there like if
there's a nail clipper on the couch
there's a nail clip on the other couch
the other day and picked it up and he
just throws it away off of the couch and
he says no i don't yucky and i'm like
wow that is the [ __ ] cutest [ __ ]
it's the cutest [ __ ] but we all have
this [ __ ] stuck in our head me
kristen and the and the nanny and my
assistant we're all walking around the
house is just like
do you like
yes i do
so we're watching this [ __ ] show the
other day which is called servant which
oh my god dude first of all don't watch
this if you have a newborn i
watched it and it's it's so good i don't
know what's up with them night shyamalan
but like he can i don't he is such a
good writer but then he'll make the
[ __ ] worst movies and those are my
favorite people if you listen to
congratulations you know those are my
favorite people the people who [ __ ]
hit and miss i don't like people who
just make good [ __ ] or just make bad
[ __ ] i like when you make the best [ __ ]
and also the most terrible [ __ ] those
are my favorite kind of people because
that means you're taking risks right and
then i'm not shy milan oh he'd be taking
some risks and this movie or this uh
apple tv show servant is so good
it's so good and you don't know what's
going on at all and you know how like
some shows
like a few episodes will go by and
they'll be like okay i'm figuring it out
dude that just straight up doesn't
happen
i'm in [ __ ] season three i don't know
what's going on dude still do you know
how hard it is to keep that tonally
moving in a horror movie and keeping it
[ __ ] keeping people along for the ride
and i still don't know where i'm going
i'm actually taking a road trip and
you're just like yeah no i don't know
where we're going
we just passed austin we came from l.a
we just passed austin and the driver's
like yeah but dude i'm not shyamalan's
in the driver's seat trust me i don't
know where we're going i know i know
where we're going trust me you're not
going to know for until we get there
and you're just like but it's been
[ __ ] days dude that's what it is
right now i'm on season two i have no
idea what's going on and i'm still
involved this show is really good but
it's about a mother who
uh their their newborn dog their newborn
dies and it's just like dude i couldn't
i i could barely get through it it was
really it's really [ __ ] up now that
i'm a dad watching this [ __ ] it's really
hard to watch
and uh the dad is a chef
and um
he is experimenting with these flavors
and [ __ ] and he makes a uh and he makes
lobster ice cream and dude we were all
watching la the the show and then once
you made lobster ice cream i was like do
you like lobster ice cream and we all
[ __ ] laughed dude and guess what man
that's the [ __ ] end of the story yes
dude told the whole [ __ ] thing about
servant just to [ __ ] tell that party
yes dude you're on board we love it
we love it dude and i don't even have my
keymap open so i couldn't do the
writer's thing
yes dude
he haphazardly does this podcast [ __ ]
but that's it dude you're raw and uncut
oh really am i yes you are dalia he's
raw and uncut you ever hear about dalia
what about him he's wrong on cut well
what do you mean dude he didn't even
open the key map in his [ __ ] last
podcast and he couldn't do the renders
thing while he was telling the story
that didn't matter are you [ __ ]
kidding me he did yep oh my oh he does
do that yep
he does
but what did he talk about dude he
talked about [ __ ] church and singing
in church and also the show servant and
he talked about it for too long really
how long 25 minutes he did how come
because he's that wrong uncut are you
serious yes
oh
thank god there's a partner like that
out there
is this the guy with the car with the
car with the bloody guts yes yes oh my
god wow that's crazy
insane dude
there it is and it's too low but it's
wrong uncut
we hit it twice the second one's louder
yes dude
we have a good time here at
congratulations
we enjoy you if you're on the patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
uh again i'll be in [ __ ] phoenix i'm
brought up with
we were i stayed watching tv this
[ __ ] week i didn't really do much
[ __ ] man i did shows i did lots of shows
but i didn't really during the daytime i
was
you ever have those days every day
you're just like man
i really gotta start working out and you
don't
like yeah sure i break strong guys
hearts and i do a lot of bodyweight
stuff but i got to get to the gym right
and it's just like okay
every day i'm like i gotta stop eating
like [ __ ]
and then i just [ __ ] late at night
get that coffee ice cream
i'll he'll take his coffee creamed too
yup he will
are you serious yup that the leah kid
wow
i
was tired i had an early morning and for
me that means 9 30. okay judge me don't
give a [ __ ] but i had an earlier moment
earlier morning and uh and so i
had a show
it was um
friday night
10 o'clock show
7 30
i'm feeling tired so i'm like look my
show's not until [ __ ] two and a half
hours and i'm not even going on first
i'm going on at like 11 something so i
got three and a half hours so i'm on the
couch so you know what i do
give up
right i don't actively go to sleep but i
do that thing where i'm like i'm on the
couch and i'm not gonna move i guess
your boy is just giving up for a few
hours okay
so my eyes get the notice
okay my breathing gets the message
it slows down
my eyes go to half mass
and then my high my eyes go fully closed
so my whole body goes like this
check you later
my body my body is in a wrestling match
with staying awake
and he just gives up okay he forfeits my
whole [ __ ]
forfeited and knew it was gonna be okay
that's really when you can forfeit right
you can't really forfeit when you know
you got [ __ ] to do but i knew i didn't
have [ __ ] to do for like four hours so
my body goes hey
you handle this other guys i'll be
asleep
so i checked out
and i wake up at about
nine
and when i wake up i'm out of sorts dude
i am out of sorts i'm i'm that i'm one
of those waking up thinking it's not
even what what what day is it it's what
planet am i on what day what day is it
on this on what planet is it
what is it is it like i could be like is
it tuesday and somebody be like no it's
actually bondi this is the planet of
uranus and these are the days for us
and i'm just like oh okay well [ __ ] how
do i get back to earth and what day is
it there like that's where i am i'm just
out to lunch on a different planet
i'm getting served all sorts of
delicacies and when they give them to me
they're just like me
and i don't know where i am okay
so i sit with it for a while
and i go upstairs and i'm waking up as
i'm walking up
now remember i gave up which means i
didn't get ready to sleep which means
i'm wearing my clothes which means
[ __ ] maybe i'll just keep them on
so i've got my jeans on i've got a shirt
on i've got i've got socks on all i do
is change my socks put on new shoes put
on a belt and then like a [ __ ] jacket
i remember and i leave
i'm awake now i go i get coffee i slurp
it up you know how i like the [ __ ] with
the purple straw i stopped by the coffee
bean and tea leaf i get the [ __ ] i sit
down for a little bit
i meet up with another dude
and then we go to the show
that we're both on
we get there and we wait
we wait to go on the both of us and a
lot of my friends are on the show we
have a good time for an hour we're
talking hanging out having a good time
i'm watching some of my friends do stand
up which i never do and i'm laughing i'm
an audience member i'm living life and
i've been awake now for hours even
though when i woke up i didn't know what
planet i was on now i know what planet
i'm back on earth
and it's friday
so the host says hey you're next and i
say great i've got a really cool leg
lakers jacket on uh black shirt
from palm angels black jeans from g-star
and [ __ ] black yeezys oh your boy's
dressed too impressed
before i go on i say do i have time to
get to go to the bathroom and he says
yup
so i go to the bathroom
i've been up for two hours already
coffee sucked down
i go to go pee pee
and i go to unbuckle my belt
and under my belt
is a belt
[Music]
i wore and was wearing
two belts
four hours
i was being a person
at places
with two belts on
i put a belt
on
over a belt
i didn't realize until i had to take
my schlong out
i unbuckled my belt
and you know how like
you know how like when you're in a
moment and something crazy happens when
you're with friends you go
oh
but then when you're in a moment or that
same kind of moment and you're by
yourself
this is the reaction you have
because there's no one to share it with
well there's another level
of not sharing a moment with someone
and it's sharing the moment with no one
i mean no one was in the bathroom with
me
and i still broke the fourth wall and
looked at nobody
i mean i unbuckled my belt noticed there
was another belt looked at an imaginary
person and i went
oh my god
no one would you ever done that you ever
broke the fourth wall to no one
i mean i wore [ __ ] two belts dude for
hours nobody knows it and then i went on
stage and i was like guys i got to
[ __ ] tell you this and i was telling
him i was like i [ __ ] have two belts
i wore two belts and i took it on my
pocket and i was like look this isn't
even a bit and they were laughing and i
was like great i'm basically carrot top
right now
just prop comics you ever wear two belts
this is where's waldo on audiocassette
i'm jean i'm hank i'm waldo there he is
um
so
yeah dude i gotta pay more [ __ ]
tension that's the peak level of just
sleepwalking through life
i mean it looks like i'm a zombie or
something
or just like i'm three just like my mom
is dressing me this way you do have two
belts
unreal dude
i gotta be that new dude that's [ __ ]
with that wears it to i'm sure there's a
rapper out there that wears two three
belts i was looking at a [ __ ] uh i
was looking at a uh my friend was
showing me tinder and he was like
he was i've never been on tinder or
anything like that i've never been on
any dating apps ever in my life and um i
was looking at i can't remember it was
tinder or bumble or something it might
have been a [ __ ] instagram bio but my
buddy showed it to me and he was like
look at this chick and he was like
and it said in her bio or something
whatever it was it was like
sapiosexuals only i'm a sapiosexual
which is somebody who's only
who's
attracted to someone's like
intellect they're attracted to intellect
which is like the most [ __ ] like why
is everything a sexuality like oh do you
just mean you like personality which is
what all chicks like nice to meet you
catch you later
oh so you're just a chick stop making
your [ __ ]
try and sound more interesting oh you
just like the way oh you like nice
people who know [ __ ]
nice to meet you
i mean get with it dude who you're
tricking the only people you're tricking
the dumb [ __ ] and you said you
want smart [ __ ]
nice to meet you dude
sayonara
sapiosexual oh you mean you just like
[ __ ] smart people
imagine how much of a cuck you'd have to
be as a dude and be like i'm actually a
sepia
sapiosexual dude no dude ever said that
because what you mean is you like
personality
and that's what chicks lead with
except for money
only hose
do you like intellect yes i do
do you like man yes i do
do you like sapiosexuals
no i don't
yucky that's what the [ __ ] cartoon
does when it does he goes like this
yucky
are you a dude yes i am do you like
intellect yes i am do you lead within do
you only are you only attracted to
intellect even when it comes to tits and
body shapes yes i am
are you a [ __ ] yes i am
yucky wow losing my mind
[Laughter]
imagine you've never seen this podcast
and that was the only clip you've seen
it dude
are you a cuck yes i am yucky losing my
mind [ __ ] it dude and for good measure
um this is kind of a you know what i did
dude i really like this episode right
now of congratulations and let me tell
you something about this episode
by mistake
i don't know why but my youtube was on
when i walked in my house a few days ago
and i was walking in
and there was a youtube episode of one
of my old podcasts on
the unfollowing remember that classic
episode
if i don't say so myself anyway i'm
joking but also it was a good one but i
watched it and i was like oh okay
and i was like i could just chill with
you [ __ ] so that's what we're
doing
and i feel like this episode is very
nice
and it's because i watched an old
episode never [ __ ] why i don't watch
this [ __ ] you know
um anyway i'm a sapiosexual i don't even
know if i'm saying that right but
i'm a i'm a sapiosexual who gets angry
sometimes you know at certain things
[ __ ] my whole thing is i do the
dishes
like that's my thing kristen actually
said to me she was like if you just
look you leave your clothes everywhere i
can't stop you you take off your [ __ ]
underwears and you throw like a throw
i'm not you leave drawers open like dude
i don't know why i do this but like i'll
open up a fork drawer take a fork out
and just won't close the door
to the fork thing and then eat with the
fork
and then put it down and then leave the
fork there and go upstairs
and she's just like why do you do that
why don't you just clean up while you're
going through what you're doing and i'm
like
i don't i don't know you know so she's
like look
if you just like i'll take my pants off
downstairs and then go upstairs and go
to sleep and my pants and downstairs
chilling and then i'll be upstairs the
next day getting ready i'll be like the
[ __ ] are my pants like i'm a walter
matthew character where's my pants
and so um
she's like look if you just
handle the dishes
get out your good dishes [ __ ]
like thanksgiving you're saying
whatever that song is
[Laughter]
get out your good dishes and pretend
like it's thanksgiving [ __ ]
sensei jake jay-z
yeah
kiddoki dishes get out your good dishes
act like it's thanksgiving and [ __ ]
um
so um
so so jay-z what do you give thanks for
this thanksgiving
dishes
um
this dish is [ __ ]
so um the good china
i like the [ __ ] gravy bowl
um
it's easter what do you like about
easter jay-z peeps [ __ ]
um so uh
butters you're a [ __ ] in-cell uh he
barked
butters you're an
butters chrisley as dog butters is an
insult
um so uh butters hasn't had sex forever
what the butter's never had sex he he
wants you so badly but chicks don't like
them butters is it chrisley his dog is
an
insult hey guys we're here we just found
out that butters is an insult
christian's dog is an insult what is it
because they removed his balls no but
it's because you know yeah
surfer dude with the long hair laughing
anyway but it's in so let's let's let's
get let's [ __ ] see what frankie muta
has been up to wow he hit a guy
um he jumped up and hit a guy
um frankie muniz is 4-2 what the [ __ ] we
found out we got his birth records and
then he grew up and frank martin's do we
just found out frankie muniz is [ __ ]
42. what the [ __ ] yeah so anyway we saw
frankie muniz really how uh you must be
looking down
sir fruity with [ __ ] long hair anyway
let's check out see what woody harrelson
is up to
oh i hit a guy
um
wow what else is it a with a sword and
an ikea he's [ __ ] slashing up [ __ ]
pride what's he slashing up prices
um so anyway um
what was i saying what the [ __ ] was i
even talking about dishes dude get out
your dishes like
like
like thanksgiving this time
jay-z caught up with jay-z jay-z what's
your favorite part of thanksgiving
dishes um so
what was i talking about dishes so
so she's like look if you just do dishes
and just make sure the dishes are
[ __ ] done
you can literally throw your pants
[ __ ] anywhere so i looked at her i
took her because sometimes you know we
don't pay attention like i was telling
you i wore two belts the other day i
took her by the hands and i said listen
sweetheart
[Laughter]
listen sweetheart it's just me and you
right now but i want you to know i'm
looking in your eyes and i'm paying
attention i wanted you to be here with
me too sweetheart
she's like what i was like listen
sweetheart
you're telling me that all i need to do
is do the dishes and i can leave the
whole house a mess as long as i just
rinse the dishes and put them in the
yeah you have to put yeah you have to
put them in the dishwasher too ah
sweetheart yeah
so let's remember this
okay
so now i do the dishes and that's all i
do and with everything else dude i'm
coming up
i want the world to know dude pants on
the [ __ ] stove just shirt on my son
throwing it on his head leaving it there
sweetheart you said the thing about the
dishes though sweetheart
[Music]
so i [ __ ] but by the way though i
said you know dishes are the i said to
her i said dishes are the worst part of
anything like i'll do laundry
[ __ ] ten times before i wanna do the
dishes and she was like that's the whole
point just do the dishes and you can do
whatever and i don't care i'll clean up
the rest of the house
so i'm like all right so i do the dishes
and i hate doing them but i do them dude
and uh
i guess my point is
dishes are just too loud dude
that's really why i brought this up
like nine times out of ten i'm doing the
dishes
and uh i'm doing it
when calvin's asleep during his nap or
i'm doing it like when i get home at 12
12 a.m because i just had to [ __ ]
level an audience
right i'm over at the laugh actor of the
improv just setting flames to a [ __ ]
wooden state you know i mean like you
know how i do right
but just
leaving the audience
different you know right like going in
the audience is one way and leaving an
audience
different
so right
so i do that and then [ __ ]
i come back i got to do the dishes and
it's always like [ __ ] god damn it
dude clankity like clank clank
you picking a dish up dude a ninja pick
up dish up and still
clank it's so annoying dude the only
thing louder is like garbage men
they gotta make quiet dishes dude
gotta make quiet [ __ ] dishes right
quiet dishes would be a [ __ ] uh
a show on uh
epics with greg kinnear
new epics original like we give a [ __ ]
oh yeah really epics original
[Laughter]
oh yeah dude
epics are written they have epics
originals
new epics originals starring greg
kinnear
quiet dishes
the [ __ ] is this about you just be you'd
be watching some [ __ ] there'll be one
small billboard on like hollywood and
highland with greg kinnear holding a
dish trying to dry it off hey we caught
up with greg kenny here the other day
hey greg what's your show about i don't
know
quiet dishes
one man
with his dishes
[Music]
honey we need quiet dishes
um worst [ __ ] show of all time
whatever dude an epics original the feel
good or no i would be about somebody
would get cancer in it you know
like that [ __ ] show shining veil like
that's a that's a [ __ ] what is that
one on what is that one on
tinder original
what's that one [ __ ] redbox original
are there redbox originals that would be
amazing if you could go to that big ass
[ __ ] drink machine with the dvds in
it and just get a red box original
with [ __ ] what's his name in it
my friend i can't even remember him wow
i wore two belts dude i can't remember
his [ __ ]
name and i know him
it would be on lifetime origin lifetime
originals i'll watch dude because those
[ __ ] kill i love those
[ __ ]
they always get the actors that haven't
been in anything for like 20
20 years i'll end up in those for sure
when i turn 60 i'll be the [ __ ] the
someone's dad someone's like rich dad
that comes to town
i just don't think it's going to work
out
lifetime original
starring five guys
and then also crystalia
the sixth lead in a lifetime original in
2041
five people who have come up through the
ranks of acting
since crystalia has been even alive and
now crystalia is his is the sixth lead
in this lifetime original
quiet dishes
we caught up with crystalia chris how
does it be in the sixth lead and i just
[ __ ] shoot him
[ __ ] you guys you did me dirty way long
ago
um
anyway you know
do some [ __ ] misconnections
fun episode man fun [ __ ] episode
actually how about this chick garcelle
beavis or whatever her name is
or no that's
oh yeah
now she's writing a book everyone's
trying to cash in on this will smith
slap apparently she dated will smith and
now she's making a book writing a book
about him
because he's the most famous guy on the
planet and then he [ __ ] and [ __ ] it
all up
will smith hasn't posted on instagram or
tick tock in a long time because he
smacked chris rock so whatever let's not
even who cares dude
can we even play this renewed life let's
watch this actually
how long was this
it's only two two minutes three minutes
let's watch it wow
wow
[Music]
i'll go out on the limb and say
white women with short hair
have to stop dancing after 35
because if you've got short hair
it's a bit
[ __ ] the turn while the house in the
back is unreal
[Music]
[Music]
breaking it down
solo
righteousness
[ __ ] that word
[Music]
here comes a turn right
[Music]
when he takes a step back
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you can't have short hair and dance like
this as an older lady
[Music]
wow got groovy again with it
gonna get so [ __ ] after the grooviness
oh
oh wow dude
the shuffle
don't they have a breakdown moment oh
yeah this works
oh
dude
it's a [ __ ]
oh so out of breath dude the [ __ ]
finger point dude
with his face
wow with the bill bellamy
mike oh dude i forgot about it
the head movement like it's on a lazy
susan
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
this that's the most dude that who's
clapping
who's clapping
who's clapping dude
so [ __ ] dude
[Music]
dude hitting the highest notes
okay not even saying [ __ ] do it
money cries at me
and i'm rising in the face
victory
and then when he does that when he hops
in the air and does the john dude guy
love john travolta would [ __ ] him would
100 make love to him and have a
full-blown relationship with him and
hide it from the church and then get
ousted from [ __ ] patience or whatever
this band is called
what's this man called hold on
the house in the back [ __ ] absolutely
destroys me dude
that [ __ ] gingerbread house in the
back
oh my god dude this is so [ __ ] the
twirly world is that he does and the
[ __ ] chick with the short hair
wow and how come you never even i tell
you what that third woman is so
nondescript that that [ __ ] the white
woman with the with the blonde hair she
could come in and [ __ ] rob me and
beat the [ __ ] out of me and the police
would be like hey who did it is it this
woman and i'd be like i don't know just
show me a picture of her i'll be like oh
no
they'd be like do you want to press
charges i'd be like no they'd be like
why not i'd be like because the renew
mine is the key
dude i can't let's look at the breakdown
again look at when he breaks it down
again
dude when he comes when it's his moment
wow dude there was a guy in my [ __ ]
high school ryan stevens used to do that
[ __ ] all the time dude everyone has that
breakdancer in his [ __ ] high school
right
here we go let's break it down again
[ __ ] let's cut this to [ __ ] one two
three four
wow five with his hands oh six tip cohen
seven with the hands oh got lower eight
and then the finger that's nine some
[ __ ] in like three
[ __ ]
seconds dude
that's the most subicious per capita in
dancing of all time dude unbelievable
wow dude
that guy is the [ __ ]
oh my god he's clark kent right now but
if he opened up his shirt like that it
would say it's a [ __ ] man
unbelievable dude
i mean dude this [ __ ] should be on
spotify that's what it says in one of
the comments
it should be on the spot if i was on
spotify dude it would make more [ __ ]
it would get more hits than joe rogan
yeah this guy says my favorite part is
that absolutely raucous applause that's
true dude that's awesome raucous that's
a great word i got to start doing that
i mean
this is wonderfully bad somebody said
it's wonderfully bad about only 13 000
views that's a crime dude
the present you know the [ __ ] nerve
you gotta have to call your band the
present
well that's it for the episode on
youtube if you want to catch the rest of
the episode the uncut episode all you
got to do is go over on our patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
and you can catch the rest of this
episode plus the rest of every other
episode that's happened in the past year
or two and also if uh
we do one extra episode on picture and
sign up for the patreon and every month
you get an extra episode that nobody
ever gets besides the people on patreon
and uh you can also get the backlog of
episodes there's like 13 14 episodes on
there right now that you can just stream
and watch right now
one after another and pretend like it's
like breaking bad also there's other
stuff like uh behind the scenes stuff on
our patreon and uh a uh what do you call
it the discord and just a bunch of stuff
patreon.comcrystalia thanks
[Music]